book salt a world history mr. car Lansky
explains the impact of the element
across many fields including engineering
religion and food during this 45-minute
event he also contends that demand for
salt has created major trade routes was
a factor in the United States
revolutionary and civil wars and helped
to instigate the overthrow of British
rule in India good evening everyone I'd
like to welcome you to politics and
prose on behalf of our owners Carla
Cohen Barbara Mead our events
coordinator cleave corner and to all the
staff who reviews the books for our
newsletter talks about the books and
sells of books generation ago you will
walk into a supermarket you could get
Morton Salt you could get kosher salt
now you go we can get gray salt black
salt five kinds of sea salt you can get
fleur de sel all kinds of things mark
Polansky has written a great book called
salt a world history it takes us back to
ancient Rome ancient Egypt China to
Gandhi's salt campaigns he brings in
chemistry politics trade and of course
many many food traditions throughout the
world you think of prosciutto parmigiano
caviar anchovies herring salt cod LOX
soy sauce fish sauce olives sour craft
all of those and there's a few recipes
also so without any further ado please
help me welcome back to politics and
prose Marc Prensky
thank you very much thank you all for
coming I realize you could have stayed
home and waited for George Bush's speech
but we have TV here also I I understand
they're gonna have some television
coverage at the Capitol also but uh you
know we'll just have to see who gets the
better ratings yeah George Bush always
says he's walking slow there's a
wonderful writer Chinese writer named
Luanne foo I don't know if any of you've
read him he wrote a great novel or
novella called the gourmet and the
gourmet is really the story of modern
China told through two characters a very
fat gourmet and a very lean
revolutionary and in the beginning of
the book the gourmet is eating a lot in
the Revolutionary is very revolted by
this and then comes the revolution and
the revolutionary becomes the manager of
the most famous restaurant in a region
of China that's famous for its great
cuisine and he redoes the restaurant
according to revolutionary ideals and it
becomes a horrible restaurant and in the
course of this book they both have their
ups and downs the Cultural Revolution
all the upheavals that our modern
Chinese history
and towards the end things are loosening
up and people are looking back at old
ways and a lot of people start saying to
the manager remember that guy the
gourmet you know he really knows a lot
about food and be interesting to have
and give a series of lectures so sort of
reluctantly the manager sets up these
lectures
and in the first lecture the gourmet
says what is the most important thing in
good cooking and people say good
ingredients how you chop the vegetables
all these they just know it's how you
use salt and everybody goes ah salt yes
the salt it's how you use the salt
lecture number two the salt how you use
the salt by the third lecture there's
only about two people coming and he's
still going on about the salt the reason
I'm telling you this story is that I
wouldn't have written a book about salt
if it was really just about salt salt is
the most spectacular example I know of
of a food commodity that had a direct
impact on the culture and religion and
politics and and science and economy of
every country in the world since before
recorded history absolutely every
country in the world has its own salt
story which kind of created a problem
for me because I didn't want to do salt
in eight volumes so you have to you have
to make choices and already you know
I've gotten some letters uh I'm from
Columbia we have a very large salt mine
it's not in your book you jerk
well you know it's my book
and writing a book is a bit like drawing
in that it's all about the choices you
make and you try to choose things that
are emblematic things that you know a
certain line a certain curve a shape
that conveys the whole in a meaningful
way you know in the same way Matisse
could do a human body with two lines
it's very much the same process in
writing so out of all the countries and
all the cultures of the world I had to
put this together with a sense of the
forward motion of of history starting
with ancient China where the first
monopolies the first state monopolies of
a commodity was the Chinese monopoly on
salt salt and iron from which they
raised money to do a lot of projects
including building the Great Wall and as
would happen later in history the salt
tax was very unpopular governments are
always drawn to taxing salt because
everybody has to use it and they use it
in about the same amount so what you're
doing is basically a poll tax and
history has shown that poll taxes are
always unpopular because there's more
poor people than rich people and the
poor people know that the rich guy isn't
paying any more in taxes and there so
this is very controversial and they the
Chinese emperor called together what
would today be called a think tank
gathered wise men from around China to
discuss the salt monopoly and they ended
up discussing absolutely everything
they discussed what is the proper degree
of intervention of government in an
economy they discussed whether it is
wise to have defense spending they
discussed whether being at war showed
bad government was a failure of
government all all of these great issues
that you know to this day remain
unsolved unanswered all because they
have decided to talk about salt I first
got interested in the subject of salt
when I was working on my book about cod
and strange I know and there was this
there was this point in history when
salt cod was a basic food of Europe of
poor people and seemed to have just a
limitless market and Europeans had by
this point found the cod banks of North
America and there seemed to be a
limitless supply of fish so the only
thing that limited this trade was the
supply of salt cod is a northern fish
and you have to cure fish with sea salt
sea salt the only way to make sea salt
economically efficient is natural solar
evaporation so you need a place with a
lot of sunshine and not much rain so for
example the English had a problem so you
see England directing their foreign
policy towards the goal of securing salt
supplies and this is what made me start
thinking about what a remarkable story
this is and you know as I went around
choosing places every place that I chose
have their own remarkable story
to any of you who know me you'll know
that if I can choose from the entire
world there's going to be Jews there's
going to be Caribbeans and there's going
to be Basques it's my book the Basques
are a good salt story because they had
neither the fish nor the salt and yet
they were leaders in both they build
great ships that could go very long
distances so they could get the fish and
then they parlayed the skill in
shipbuilding with Genoa in trading
shipbuilding for salt and they were
among the first people to develop this
market and salt cod without actually
owning any salt or any fishing grounds
in the Caribbean
there were many places I could have
chosen from the Caribbean is an example
of this north/south thing much of the
Caribbean is just ideal for salt making
and much of the salt that was used in
the fisheries in New England and
Atlantic Canada came from the Caribbean
and I chose two places one of them in
the Bahamas and one in the Turks and
Caicos and the Turks and Caicos are kind
of they used to be part of the Bahamas
but they did not go the path of
Independence ever in fact during the
American Revolution Americans who were
opposed to the Revolution went to the
Turks and Caicos and it's still a
British colony today the island in the
Bahamas great in nagua is kind of the
the salt reality of today the island is
virtually owned by morton salt
they control e they own the salt works
they own the only hotel in the island
which is a guesthouse and you know the
only store where you can buy food and
you know if if you lost your job with
Morton on Graydon agua and you know
you're left on bad terms I think you
would have to leave the island the place
in the Turks and Caicos a place called
salt Key it's just the opposite kind of
story
it was private entrepreneurs very small
really it was the salt equivalent of the
sugar cane plantation it was slave based
labor they built this house overlooking
instead of overlooking the fields and
overlooked the ships and the salt ponds
they were so distrustful that the salt
was stored in their houses the basement
and first floor there was no floor
between the basement and the first floor
and the whole bottom of the house was a
salt warehouse they're still salt and a
few of these houses are still there and
there's still some salt in the in the
basement but they don't make salt and
salt key anymore because we live in a
world today in which small companies
don't do very well in the salt market
because you have to move a lot of salt
to make money so it's the sluices are
open and the the ponds are still there
and all the roads are are made out of
salt but there's no salt making going on
it's the only place I've ever been where
you could you could walk from the
airport to the capital city and the only
means of transportation is golf carts
all the locals have golf carts and you
can rent a golf cart drive along any
salt roads kind of quickly realize that
the locals were driving much faster than
I was
because it turned out that the rental
golf carts had had the thing turned down
and I figured out there's some little
thing by the carburetor under the seat
and you turn it up and you can really
move
than these things but it's a small
island so I did this for one day and I
was bombing all over the island having a
great day and then at night I was in the
only bar shooting pool and the guy who
rents the golf carts came up to me and
said you turned up your car didn't you
it turned it down tomorrow you can't get
away with anything not a small Caribbean
island the choices I had to make you
know you had to make choices within
choices like Italy is and the Roman
Empire was clearly very important to the
history of salt but when you realize
that every major city and the Italian
peninsula was founded on salt if you
have to decide you know which salt
stories to do scenting in France and the
interesting thing about France is that
it has a Mediterranean coast in an
Atlantic coast in there and there was a
huge historic shift after after America
was discovered after they discovered
that you could get to Asia by leaving an
Atlantic port and going around Africa
suddenly the Mediterranean was no longer
the center of the world and ports like
Amsterdam and Antwerp and Seville
started to become very important and all
the action moved from the Mediterranean
to the Atlantic and the same thing
happened with salt suddenly there were
major salt sea salt centres along the
Atlantic coast and Mediterranean salts
started fading I went to I went to the
Dead Sea which in Hebrew is called the
salt sea and there's a mountain there
mount Sodom which is almost pure salt
has been mined for salt for about 10,000
years and has a pillar that's broken
away that's supposed to be Lot's wife
and it's on postcards just sort of a
tourist attraction and absolutely every
geologist that I talked to in Israel
told me that they were absolutely
certain that this column is going to
fall over within the next five years so
I thought well you know the collapse of
Lot's wife
what more can happen to Israel if they
said don't worry this is the third Lot's
wife we've had the amazing thing about
the Dead Sea works is that the Dead Sea
is on the arab-israeli border on the
border with Jordan and the Jordanians
built a sea salt operation to mirror the
Israeli one they're right next to each
other and they're and they're identical
so there is a place where the Arab world
in the Israeli world have a border in
the middle of salt ponds there's
actually there's a dike with a and the
salt pond on this side is Israel and the
salt pond on the side is is Jordan I was
actually in the Dead Sea area at the
last peaceful moment before it all blew
up and it was a you know for a few weeks
it was looking very very hopeful because
there's all this salt around and there's
also tourism because of you know baths
in the in the Dead Sea and you had the
the borders of Jordan and Israel and the
occupied territory and the Palestinian
Authority all these borders meet in this
in this salt area and it all seemed to
be working out so well and everybody was
making lots of money and silly me I for
a moment thought
I even almost wrote an article about it
how you know the piece could work in the
Middle East because everybody was making
money afraid was a very American idea it
didn't it didn't work out that way
salt was an extremely valuable commodity
not only because everybody needs salt to
live and because salt preserves food so
in northern climates at anyway you could
not get through a winter without salting
food but also until there was a
refrigeration you couldn't take a
perishable food and turn it into a
successful commodity of international
trade without salting it so it it was a
miraculous source of wealth for
millennia and because of that it took on
all kinds of cultural and religious
significance almost every religion in
the world has some sort of salt related
beliefs most of which have to do with
the preservation function of salt which
can be looked at two ways there's the in
the Jewish religion and in the Muslim
religion salt seals bargains between man
and God or between two people but
there's also the notion because salt
prevents rot that it keeps away evil in
Haitian voodoo salt is the only way to
restore a zombie salt is salt was used
in in the Catholic religion for to to
preserve children until they could be
baptized it in
almost every religion there's some sort
of salt belief most indigenous American
religions have salt gods and it's
because salt was absolutely vital so
what happened to ruin this whole thing
geology which was a a very slow
developing science and the commercial
side of geology for a long time was
about prospecting for salt and
geologists looked in particular for what
were called salt domes which were these
columns of pure sodium chloride that
they didn't know then but we now know go
miles and miles into the earth the salt
dome in Avery Island in Louisiana is
seven miles straight down pure sodium
chloride so you get a salt dome and
you've got a long long time supply of
salt but the problem was that the salt
was coming up all kinds of black and
mucky and they tried to wash it off but
it was hard to wash and eventually they
realized that this black muck was oil
and it turns out that oil and natural
gases are filed around the edge of salt
domes the ancient Chinese actually knew
this about 2,000 BC there was a man
named Li Bing who was a hydraulic
engineering genius built the first Dam
and he said you know when you see these
pools of brine lying around us because
there's a salt water underneath then you
just drill and you can get a source of
salt so they started drilling and people
were getting sick and there were
explosions and there were fires and
gradually they came to realize that
Dragons lived under the
and about once a year they would come do
things to appease the Dragons and slowly
they started realizing that there was
some kind of invisible substance it was
natural gas and they started using it to
to heat the brine and to cook it down
into into salt this was by 200 ad they
were doing this so when I was
researching this book and I was in Avery
Island which is owned by a family
McIlhenny family which makes Tabasco
sauce and they lease out the salt mine
to a corporation and they leased out the
oil in the gas to another corporation
and I was visiting the salt mine which
was run by the Cargill company and they
were talking about the problems of
making making it keeping it economically
feasible because you have to keep the
price of salt down to to make it
profitable and they said that one of the
big problems was the the cost of energy
and I said well you know you're
surrounded by oil and natural gas why
don't you just use that and they said
we're Cargill that's Exxon nowadays we
know that there's salt everywhere
because once they started once they
discovered that there was oil and salt
domes they started drilling salt domes
everywhere and in the in the early 20th
century the technology of drilling in
the Western world had not caught up to
medieval China but within about 10 or 15
years it got very sophisticated and they
started going to the Middle East and the
places where Herodotus had talked about
salt and they found oil and once they
got really good at drilling into the
earth they discovered that there was
salt everywhere and that just kind of
ruined it
so one of the things that I like about
the salt story is that it ends up being
the story of the notion of wealth and
how fragile and what an illusion wealth
can be I just want to end by reading two
paragraphs from the end of the
introduction today thousands of years of
coveting fighting over hoarding taxing
and searching for salt appear
picturesque and slightly foolish the
17th century British leaders who spoke
with urgency about the dangerous
national dependence on French sea salt
seems somehow more comic than
contemporary leaders concerned with the
dependence on foreign oil
in every age people are certain that
only the things they have deem valuable
have true value the search for love and
the search for wealth are always the two
best stories but while a love story is
timeless the story of a quest for wealth
given enough time will always seem like
the vain pursuit of a mirage thank you
very much thank you I'd love to take
some questions and I've been asked to
make an announcement see this mic here
it's it's brand new it's wonderful it's
exciting and I I have sworn to make you
all stand up there when you ask your
questions so now that I've completely
intimidated it's a nice it's a friendly
looking mic
um it's a pleasure to hear you speak all
your books cover so much world history
in so much territory I'm just curious
how you go about researching your books
because the documents that you look at
must I don't know where they would be
contained that they cover so much
territory so if you could talk about how
you research now yeah I mean it's um
it's a little different on each book for
this book there actually are a lot of
documents about salt there's you know
records going back to ancient times all
of the important ancient writers or you
know cleany wrote about salt and you can
there the dialog that I was talking
about in ancient China was published you
can read it I have the good fortune to
live in New York because the New York
Public Library is a particularly good
resource for food history has quite a
few things including you know original
documents on the fight one of the major
issues of the French Revolution was the
salt tax and there are you know first
hand documents in the New York Public
Library on this but I also find it very
important to travel the places see
things firsthand talk to people but
mainly see things because otherwise you
can't really describe things well and
unless you've seen them and you can't
really get a sense of them unless you
unless you've seen them
yeah please yeah a really good part of
your book today just just waiting for
you to show up I should have waited
longer yeah maybe I buy two copies of
the book and you are very interesting
thank you two questions in Kanawha
Valley the salt produced there by
evaporation was called Kanawha read from
the color of the soil which was loaded
with iron do you know what's what that
canola red looked like can you make a
comparison um I can guess yeah um it was
not red I don't think it was red like I
don't know if you've seen this Hawaiian
salt which is just loaded with clay and
it ended it
it looks like powdered clay I don't
think it was like that I think that you
know most of these salts red salt black
salt stuff it's it's really more a tint
than a color I suspect it was sort of
rusty ish color reddish rather than real
in red the other thing is Booker T
Washington when he was became a free boy
I think he was twelve years old when he
started working in the the salt furnaces
in what was then called canoas salines
and your description of working in that
kind of environment was much more
difficult than the physical exertion of
being a slave but a big difference in
terms of years of being a sense of
yourself that he chose that rather than
staying in a more comfortable life in in
Virginia and I think that's a real
insight that your book didn't he uh-huh
that is very interesting it was
tremendously
dangerous brutal work it was at a time
when the plantation system was in
decline in Virginia and Virginia slave
owners would would rent out their slaves
to the Saltworks but it was a considered
a nightmare and the worst fate that
could befall you thanks
I have a sociological question what does
the expression below the salt mean below
the soft below the salt yeah people get
seated below with us yeah um I believe
that this is mainly aa British at least
that I haven't run into it anywhere but
with the British and it was a reference
to the the the seating order at a table
the salt the main salt cellar which at
one time was incredibly ornate yeah they
could be huge for a while in their 16th
and 17th century they were these giant
ships ah and they would they would have
a drawer in it that had salt and often
they would have another juror that had
an antidote to poison there was all this
symbolism to it you know it was the ship
of state and the ship of state would
last forever because it was preserved by
salt but just in case there was the
antidote for the poison and and the the
the seating was you know if you were
where you were in relation to this salt
which was exactly in front of the
monarch was you know your whole pecking
order I told you everything if you were
just stuck there below the salt
thanks thank you yeah I was first about
the health effects of salting so many
foods back in the sixteen hundreds or
whatever they were doing yeah um I mean
salt foods were very salty you know like
bacon today you know we salt just
because we've gotten to like the taste
of it but it's not really salted enough
to preserve it we put it in the
refrigerator but it used to be bacon
used to be something like salt cod you
had to soak it before you used it and if
things were really salty this whole
debate about the health implications of
salt has gone back you know through all
of recorded history and has never been
resolved how much salt is unhealthy
there was an ancient Chinese writer who
wrote that excess of salt caused high
blood
pressure is it's not clear is it isn't
it
exactly what the implications of salt
are if if you have healthy kidneys
you're supposed to be able to process
excess salt but the you know anecdotal
evidence is there's there seems to be a
lot of health problems connected with
people who eat a lot of salt it's not
clear why I'm sorry I lost track of
which original question was was it today
answer it no just curious if you had the
insight from the book about whether
there was a sense that was having a
detrimental effect of people's health
here it's not it's not it's not clear is
it it's not clear that it is um the
second question I had was um you know I
just lived in the San Francisco Bay Area
and there you can see all the salt
drying areas and it's you know it was a
very urban area it just seems amazing to
me that they're using that land I guess
for that purpose and also that they're
still drying it using you know solar
radiation isn't there some more
high-tech method that's really the way
they do it still it is the most
cost-effective way you know you have to
to make salt to make a profit on it you
have to produce it for cheap this is the
cost-effective way of doing it it's the
only sea salt works left in the United
States it's a it goes back to
pre-columbian times it's an ideal place
where there's wind and Sun and it's very
a very efficient spot or for making salt
and it's always been profitable there's
this wonderful story about the camels so
somebody got an idea during the the
silver boom in Nevada the you solved for
mining silver and this was a great boom
for salt making in San Francisco if
somebody got this great idea to get
Asian camels and bring them to San
Francisco and have them carry the salt
over the Sierra Nevadas and so they got
the camels and you know about half of
them died before they got him to San
Francisco and then they got them they
loaded them up they brought them to
Nevada and first of all horses didn't
like them at all
these camels would come into this mining
town and all the horses would just go
nuts so it passed all these laws
outlawing camels in the city limits and
there was this complete chaos cause
everywhere in the Old West might be this
herd of camels ends up being kind of a
sad story they just left them out in the
desert and they probably died nobody you
know they just vanished but it seems
like this huh that symbol just go bare
it doesn't seem like terribly clean
water does it but the salt is just fine
how does it well you wash it wash it
after its dried you yeah you try to get
it under Crystal and you you you wash it
there's a there's a saturation point
salt water will only hold a certain
amount of salt so you can if you get
water to that point you can wash an
assault and it doesn't melt the salt
because it can't hold any more but it's
yeah it's condensed San Francisco Bay
anyone else is there such a thing as a
manufactured salt I mean is you say sea
salt so they evaporate the water from
San Francisco Bay or somewhere else but
is there such a thing as DuPont salt or
you know ah as it chemically made is it
it in any way no reason to there's
there's so much by the time you know
technology got to the awful state where
you could do everything artificially
salt was so abundant it it wouldn't be
it wouldn't be worth doing there's um
you couldn't possibly manufacture an
artificial salt as cheaply you know as
you can rake the Bonneville Salt Flats
or Mynaa
a salt dome or dry out seawater it's
really very cheap very low technology
second
when when when you refer to like um like
rock salt you know whether using roads
and stuff and other salt that's used in
I don't in manufacturing and whatever in
in non and non-food uses up is that the
same its assault assault a generic term
that that applies to all those are those
different products our salt is an acid
that acts on a base so a lot of things
are solved not all salts are edible so
that I mean we like to eat sodium
chloride there's also potassium chloride
which you can eat but it's usually used
for potash for fertilizer there's
magnesium chloride but within just
sodium chloride which is the salt we'd
like to eat there are a lot of uses and
the the grade of refining you know from
the the cheapest sodium chloride this is
amazing the the largest use for salt in
the United States is de-icing roads and
that's just the cheapest you just take
the stuff and crush it it doesn't have
to be clean you know and then there are
various other grades till you get to
pharmaceuticals which use salt a lot but
it has to be very highly refined so
there's all different levels and of
course you know as you go up the levels
that become more valuable but they cost
more to produce is it true then that
there is no salt made in the Great Salt
Lake of Utah the salt the salt flats 5-2
Salt Lake yeah produce and you just rake
it up it's actually why the Mormons
moved to that place as they saw this as
a place they were looking for a place
where you know it had a lot of problems
and they were looking for a place where
they could just be by themselves and be
self-sufficient so there's this place in
the middle of nowhere and they can make
salt it was ideal thank you could you
tell us about a couple of the more
interesting wars fought over sell
I presume there have been some so yeah I
mean there's two things there's worse
there's a lot of wars that were financed
by salt such as the Punic War and then
there were wars that were fought over
salt the American Revolution was not
fought over salt but saw fault salt was
fought over in the American Revolution
when when the British took long island
the George Washington and the
Continental Army lost their salt supply
and the thing about salt in history is
that not only two people need salt but
livestock do so an army does if you have
horses if you have livestock for me you
have to have large supplies armies
marched on salt in the Civil War salt
was a very important issue the the North
produced a lot of salt and the South got
most of its salt from it have some salt
works but it depended on salt from the
British who used cheshire salt as
ballast for the cotton trade they would
come with ships full of salt unload the
salt in New Orleans and pick up cotton
and if four days after Fort Sumner
Lincoln declared an embargo the south
blockade a naval blockade and no British
salt could get in and the South became
absolutely desperate for salt during the
entire civil war it was a major problem
not only for the Confederate Army just
but also for people's daily lives and
there was a whole campaign fought a
forgotten campaign of the Civil War and
the Gulf Coast of Florida there were all
of these
sea salt works and the Union Navy was
constantly raiding them and wrecking
them the Union Navy the Union had a
policy of seeking out southern salt
works and destroying and wherever they
found them they tried to destroy them
and so there was this campaign that went
on during the entire Civil War of
destroying salt water
in the Gulf Coast of Florida doesn't
take much to build a Saltworks Oh months
later it would be back and then the Navy
would come back and destroy it again
but of course one of the really
interesting Wars salt wars is the French
Revolution the the French salt
administration was one of the really hot
sources of anger at the monarchy not
only because it made salt expensive but
because the the rules were different in
different parts of France which made the
prices hugely different so you had
places with cheap salt and places with
expensive salt so salt smuggling became
a way of life and the prisons in France
were just full of thousands of people
who had been arrested for the crime of
salt smuggling and became this very
bitter thing and one of the major issues
of the French Revolution and Gandhi
began the the movement to overthrow the
British for Indian independence with the
issue of salt so that's some I'm reading
salt right now I've actually just read a
couple chapters and I'm enjoying it very
much but I have to say that my heart
belongs to Cod what do I say to that
yeah and I've given it as gifts to
people and I've lent it out in fact I
had to buy a new copy de-excite lost
track of where that went um but it's
kind of a hard sell when you try to
suggest that people read Cod they sort
of you know they don't know exactly what
they what to expect now that you've lost
your heart to Cod I was just wondering
if you could talk a little bit of sort
of your how you how you came up with the
idea to write about Cod was it a
difficult idea to sell to a publisher
and you know it's basically done it's
actually it's an odd sort of evolution
over the years of you know Cod things
kept happening in my life
I worked as a fisherman when I was young
and I a lot of places I went as a
journalist the Basques were you know I
went to Basque Country and salt cod was
a religion and I was a Caribbean
correspondent for a long time and you
know salt was there and a cod was there
and everywhere I went cod was saying and
the idea of the book really sort of
cemented when I was doing an
environmental story for Audubon magazine
on the coast of England about the
disappearance of the cod stocks there
and I just started piecing together all
these all of these different things and
and at the same time there was a British
publisher who asked me if I had an idea
for a small book and so I put together
this idea for him but of course as often
happens with small British publishers he
forgot to mention anything about money
so I sold it to an American but that's
more or less how it came about I have to
agree about cod it's it's the reasonable
in your heart I I think I had an idea
that that salt was a big story I mean
we've heard references you know to salt
before it's not an original idea but Cod
was really sort of original and I had no
idea I would enjoy that book when I got
it but but I did you're thoroughly
engrossing and entertaining gentleman I
thoroughly enjoyed that book I'm looking
forward to enjoying cod I mean salt the
two seem to go together you alluded to
the fact though that that this was a big
subject and so two questions in one may
be yeah will there be a salt number two
and and I'll - well you know some people
are reading this book so fast I think if
I had I think if i had started reading
this book yesterday i may not have been
here today because i would have finished
at sea but if not a salt number two
because you did allude to that
being a big subject what what do you
think might be your your next subject
there's not going to be a salt
- sure there was a salt - you know
didn't work out you know there's almost
an accidental trilogy going between the
cod book the bass book in the salt book
they all do go together but that's it my
next book is on the history of the year
1968 around the world trying to
understand why all of these movements
over completely different issues did the
exact same things at the exact same time
it's a unique phenomena of history so
and probably won't be any recipes isn't
it yeah okay
great thank you all very much thank you
I'd be happy to sign books for anybody
on me right here if you can help us by
folding up the chairs real quick
books mark Kerr Lansky is author of Cod
a biography of the fish that changed the
world the Basque history of the world
and his latest salt a world history it's
published by Walker & Company
visit the website Walker ebooks.com to
learn more